la abstención fue la gran vencedora de
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones en
las 18 regiones que componen francia se
calcula que 30 y 15 millones de
franceses esto es casi un 66 por ciento
del electorado no fue a votar este
domingo es un poco menos que el domingo
pasado cuando la abstención marcó un
récord de la quinta república francesa
el sistema político que rige este país
desde 1958 en ese contexto el bloqueo
republicano es decir la unión de todos
los partidos en contra de la extrema
derecha fue el gran vencedor sobre todo
en la región paca provenza-alpes-costa
azul a allí el candidato de la derecha
del partido de los republicanos en un
mussolini incluso con el apoyo de la
izquierda se impuso al candidato del
partido de extrema derecha de marie le
pen agrupación nacional era la única
región donde este partido tenía
posibilidades de llevarse una
presidencia de región por lo tanto el
partido de marie le pen se queda sin
ninguna región pero estas elecciones
también han marcado una suerte de
renacimiento de la derecha tradicional
del partido de los republicanos dos de
sus ex miembros ya vive acá en el norte
del país en los altos de francia y leidi
en la región antes de parís han sido
reelectos así como uno de sus actuales
miembros luego un bosque en la región o
bérnia ródano alpes esto envía
directamente un mensaje al presidente
manuel macro puesta hasta ahora de cara
a las presidenciales del próximo año los
sondeos siempre lo daban a él en una
segunda vuelta frente a marine lepén sin
embargo ahora la derecha se plantea como
una verdadera alternativa que incluso
tendría mejores posibilidades de
imponerse a la extrema derecha en un
eventual balotaje más todavía que el
presidente manuel matrona